from hot skating Barbie to depression
Barbie the iconic doll goes by many
names professions and identities he is
every Barbie in the Barbie movie
explained spoilers ahead
the main Barbie who everyone knows and
loves is played by Margot Robbie and her
special quality is literally in her name
stereotypical Barbie as said by her
she's exactly what you'd expect when
someone would ask you to imagine Barbie
bleached blonde hair a fun and upbeat
attitude that never breaks under near
perfect physique she's literally seen as
the ideal image of Barbie which is
likely why Ryan Gosling's stereotypical
Ken wants to be with her she works
alongside the other Barbies in Barbie
land to maintain their ideals and sense
of power while also living in the iconic
Barbie Dream House however her ideal
view of the world is broken when her
former Child glorious starts to feel
depressed about her dwindling
relationship with her daughter and
unfulfilling life so she sets out on an
adventure with Ken to discover that all
her beliefs about Barbie's inspiring
women wasn't actually true in the real
world in actuality women are continually
set back by the dominating patriarchy
and struggle to find positions of power
as they do in Barbie land which crushes
Barbie's Spirit however through her
reference to take back Bobby lands and
help the Barbies regain their
independence after can take over in her
absence Barbie ends up making
self-discoveries that change her life
and begins to lead a new life as a human
maybe now she can be the ordinary Barbie
that Gloria dreams of
with Barbie land having a functioning
government run by the Barbies there must
be someone on the top right well that
Barbie is President Bobby who is played
by Issa Ray president Barbie reminds
every one of her position by always
having a presidential sash displayed and
being the head of all the big meetings
that happen in Barbie land president
Bobby's highly viewed stature and
distinctive charm show why the Barbie's
love and respect her as a leader believe
it or not there was actually president
Barbie that was created for the 2012
election called the Barbie I can be USA
president Dal while Rey's version of the
doll iteration isn't heavily tied to
that doll there's actually a new Barbie
doll based on President Barbie in the
film that's been created so it seems
like girls of a new generation can be
inspired by this new president Barbie
the spider strengths as a leader though
president Barbie is also brainwashed by
the Kens into serving their needs
luckily she snaps out of it like the
rest of her Barbie cohorts and is
rightfully reinstated in her role as
president by the end of the film
I'm weird Barbie I am in the splits I
have a funky haircut and I smell like
basement oh my God I
Barbie yeah you did well most of the
Barbies in Barbie land of what fans
would expect happy Near Flawless looking
and thriving weird Barbie isn't as
fortunate weird Barbie is unfortunately
the result of what happens when kids
play with their Barbies too hard she has
colored drawings on her face her hair
has been cut apart and even burned a bit
and worst of all she's stuck during the
splits and forced to live in a Twisted
Dream House on a hill away from the rest
of the Barbies we had Bobby's eccentric
personality as a result of her being
twisted and contorted by kids throughout
the years weird Barbie is truly treated
like a leper in Barbie land and most of
the Barbies only go to see her to feel
better about themselves however weird
Barbie ends up being the reason that the
Barbies reclaimed Bobby land she helps
put together a Revolt along with some
discontinued Barbies and a couple of old
cans weird Barbie helps rally together
the Barbies and concoct a plan to save
Barbie land from the Cairns by the end
the weird Barbie gained a recognition
and respect of the other Barbies and is
now seen as a true Barbie
not all Barbie's work and live on land
some fly up into space or even exist as
mermaids in the vast blue plastic sea
mermaid Barbies all play by Dua Lipa are
some of the most unique Barbies in
Barbie land and they make for some very
fun surprises in the film not only do
they appear with their gorgeous colored
hair and Shining Tails but they
generally give off Good Vibes they're
always seen saying hello to everyone on
the beach and one of them even wishes
Barbie well before she goes off on her
journey to the real world there's even a
mermaid cam played by John Cena that
swims alongside the mermaid Barbies
mermaid versions of Barbie are an iconic
staple of the Barbie doll Legacy and
feature some of the most eye-catching
designs from their incredible color
palettes to their Strong Style variety
there's nothing more visually memorable
and mesmerizing than a mermaid Barbie so
although mermaid Barbies might be stuck
in the sea they are a key part to the
different ways that Barbies can be found
throughout Barbie land
the film's depiction of Bobby's history
of burying looks and Designs is
incredibly deep and even features some
versions of the character that I've
rarely seen including ones with physical
disabilities back in one of the trailers
fans can spot a Barbie that works
alongside president Barbie who has a
prosthetic arm it gave some inkling that
we could see more Barbies with
disabilities in a movie somewhere and
luckily there's another that can be
prominently seen in the film drawing a
couple sequences including the film's
extravagant's early dance number there
can be a Barbie spotted dancing in her
wheelchair all of these women are Barbie
and Barbie is all of these women as
mentioned by the Barbies they're meant
to represent everything that women can
be and Inspire everyone to be their best
selves so the inclusion of Barbies with
disabilities solidifies her ideology and
it's a great reminder of how Barbie has
become a brand for everyone it's a great
nod to both Barbies with prosthetic arms
and legs as well as ones that come with
wheelchairs both of which actually exist
and a meaningful inclusion that further
highlights the film's diverse depictions
as we meet the wide variety of Barbies
found throughout land we come across a
Barbie making an impassioned speech in
course with some powerful words and a
strong conviction this is lawyer Barbie
played by Sharon Rooney and she's not
someone you would want to face in court
she's incredibly skilled at convincing a
jury to take aside and can easily win
everyone in the courtroom over through
her strong line delivery along with a
noteworthy introduction Rooney delivers
the perfect kind of performance to make
lawyer Barbie stand out although she
displays strong Independence and a good
ability to sway others she ends up
falling under the same spell that all
the other Barbies do when the Ken's take
over thankful each is able to be snapped
back to reality just in time to help the
Barbies pull off their big plan in
Barbie land every Barbie could use a
great lawyer and lawyer Barbie should
always be their first call among the
core friend group are stereotypical
Barbie is writer Barbie an incredibly
intellectual Barbie who has a sharp
tongue and an incredible writing ability
that's led to a very successful career
played by Alexandra ship brighter
Barbie's work is so renowned that we see
that it earns her a Nobel Prize at the
beginning of the film given that she's
the first person stereotypical Barbie
waves hello to every morning it's safe
to say that they're pretty close
although writer Barbie is witty and
Incredibly capable of nearly anything
she tries she still manages to be
brainwashed by the Cairns though at
least she's the first Barbie to be
converted back from there she's shown to
be one of the Barbie's best assets and
is a key reason that they're eventually
able to turn the tables
another incredibly intelligent member of
stereotypical Bobbies core friendship
group is physicist Barbie a Barbie who's
earned a Nobel Prize for a work in
physics this Barbie played by Emma
Mackey doesn't get much screen time but
she does have some aspects through
outside of her career that make her
stand out not only did she have some
adorable freckles on her face but she
has a close friendship with one of the
cans played by shooty gatwa however that
friendship takes an unfortunate term
when the Ken's take over and physicist
Barbie ends up trading out a lab coat
from Maids outfit thankfully when the
Barbies reclaim Barbie land physicist
Barbie is able to return to her former
life and even maintain her friendship
with her favorite Ken while we don't get
to know physicist Barbie or that well
she still maintains her role as a highly
intelligent member of the Barbies and
could maybe find a bigger role if a
sequel ever comes
you bring your rollerblades
I literally go nowhere without them well
it might not be a different Barbie
altogether there is a moment where we
see stereotypical Barbie deliver a nod
to another iconic Barbie figure when she
comes to the real world as she and Ken
into the real world they slide in on
some sweet roller skates and wear
outfits that feel like a legit throwback
a psychedelic style and bright colors
are a total treat for the eyes and
actually act as a reference to a very
memorable Barbie doll known as hot
skating Barbie the doll debuted back in
1994 and featured the same type of
clothes style and of course roller
skates that Barbie wears in the film for
long time fans it's a fantastic
reference to an all-time favorite doll
variant and it's easily a part of one of
the most memorable sequences of the film
sure it could have been cool to see
someone representing hot skating Barbie
back in Barbie land but stereotypical
Barbie and Ken putting on outfits in our
honor is pretty rad too oh
foreign
[Applause]
there's a Barbie who might not win a ton
of awards like her friends will be the
most popular around town but instead
save lives which is arguably more
important Dr Bobby played by Harvey Neff
is one of the most important Barbies
around as she has the skills to heal and
save anyone who gets injured whether
it's a can who got hurt and trying to
surf the plastic waves or a Barbie who
had a workplace Accident Dr Barbie is
always ready to answer the call but that
doesn't mean that she can't party and
have fun like the rest of the Barbies
she too is tricked by the Kens into
falling into their patriarchal ways but
is saved by her fellow Barbies but Dr
Barbie doll is an iconic variant from
bodies of Barbie is all about being a
symbol that showed that women were
capable of being anything just like a
doll counterpart Dr Bobby shows her
importance in this world and is one of
the notable standouts in the vast Barbie
cast
it seems like there are lots of Award
winners in this crowd of Barbies as
journalist Barbie played by Rito Aya has
made her own achievements in journalism
she's not only a Pulitzer winner but
she's easily the top reporter in Barbie
land she's not afraid to get to the
bottom of some of the hardest hitting
stories and is a great speaker in front
of the camera when the Kens do take
control of Barbie land she isn't able to
maintain her stature and ends up being
just another Pawn in the Ken's game
Butch is able to earn back her
credibility once the Barbies regain
power and take back her position of
being the best reporter in town
a stereotypical Bobby becomes more
gutted by her views of the world being
dismantled she becomes consumed by
depression with everything that happens
in Barbie land influencing Mattel's
output of the Dolls it doesn't take long
for a new version of the Barbie doll
called depression Barbie to release and
audiences are treated with a hilarious
commercial centered around the dolls
these dolls cry struggle to see the
brighter side of life and they're
constantly having an existential crisis
about death they embody the dark and
somewhat's hilarious turn that Barbie
has taken in the film and the scene
leaves such an impact he can't help but
wish that these dolls were real you know
definitely not nothing about death
anymore the Prussian Bobby is easily one
of the funniest parts of the entire film
and the Darkly humorous take on the
usually empowering and positive feeling
dolls eventually with the help of the
other Barbies and Gloria stereotypical
Bobby is able to get out of this mental
Funk and find her own path forward
however it's hard not to live what came
out of Barbie's saddest moment since
depression Barbie is probably the most
unique Barbie of all